pencil pushers what can you do huh bad
blood is actually taking place shortly
after the event of watchdogs the last
time you spoke to t-bone in watch dogs
it was telling you that he was about to
put a false trail in the blue system and
leave Chicago for good and as you're
starting bad blood you're exactly doing
that so like you uh plate today you're
trying to put a false trail and blue
system but you're receiving a weird call
from an old coworker Tobias a character
you also met in in watch dogs and easing
trouble so t-bone as to choice right now
it's to either leave Chicago for good or
elf is old friend and well you can
figure out what option is going to take
so he's gonna try to help Tobias get out
of trouble and by doing so they're
slowly gonna realize that there's a a
bigger plan behind all this and this is
where the story of a blog will unfold so
Babylon is really about exploring
t-bones t-boned past so it's up it's a
really rich character that people love
and we really wanted to push the story
in order to explore is as fast but also
let you know a little bit more about his
future so that's what pretty much the
story behind bad Lloyd out sorry no
don't take it
my insurance the street suite fantasy is
a new type of socket aside content that
we've created and that is that is part
of the story and the fantasy that is
related to t-bone but not only you have
a great single-player experience with a
new story and new character and a main
campaign but you also have this this
endless new content that is you know
procedurally generated and infinite that
you can either experience in single
player or with a friend by matchmaking
or by flex with someone it is in your
friend list so just like watch dogs just
like we wanted that experience to be
symbolized between multiplayer and bingo
player with acting inhaling by example
co-op is exactly meant to be the same
thing so we really want you to
experience the street suite mission
between main mission as you're playing
and enjoy them with a friend which is
pretty cool so it's also bringing a
really great value to the DLC since well
their infinite so it's really am Finn it
fun and every mission feel fresh and
unique because objectives and locations
or match so that's a really a really
great addition to a bad light all that
just for little old me
you